das ist eine krasse zahl sagenhafte
21.000 us zu ihnen um schweren die erde
und kommen uns dabei gefährlich nach
berechnungen der nasa liegt die
wahrscheinlichkeit von einem
neugeborenen im laufe seines lebens den
einschlag eines 100 meter großen
armageddon hast du eben zu erleben bei
erschreckenden 5 prozent doch um dieses
aber gern zu verhindern soll jetzt
endlich gehandelt werden unter anderem
mit laserstrahlen wie soll das denn
bitte funktionieren krieg zum zweiten
kriegstag gespann des seins videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
wir kennen rund 21.000 sogenannte near
earth objects kurznews diese erdnahe
objekte sind asteroiden die im weltraum
die erde umschwirren und eine
kollisionsgefahr mit unserem planeten
bergen in den letzten 20 jahren hat die
rate an entdeckung solcher neos rapide
zugenommen
expert man expertin zufolge kennen wir
damit aber nur etwa die hälfte der
objekte die tatsächlich um die ehre erde
stören nur von den großen körpern sind
wohl über 90 prozent bereits bekam
ständig schlagen kleine hast du ihn bei
uns auf der erde ein meistens in
irgendwelchen entlegenen gebieten größe
ratgebern brocken die eine immense
verwüstung anrichten würden zum glück
nicht zu oft statistisch gesehen nur
alle 5000 jahre größere asteroiden mit
500 metern durchmesser schlagen sogar
nur alle 300 tausend jahre ein aber sie
tun es und das eben regelmäßig und auch
die richtigen killer asteroiden tun es
der letzte treffer etwa 66 millionen
jahren an der nordspitze der
mexikanischen yucatan halbinsel auf und
hinterließ einen 180 kilometer großen
krater der extreme aufprall setzte eine
energie frei die atombomben um ein
millionenfaches übertraf aufgewirbelter
staub asche und co2 sorgten vermutlich
dafür dass sich der planet verdunkelte
und in der darauffolgenden frostperiode
alle lebewesen starben die größer als
ein hamster waren die evolution wurde
quasi auf null gesetzt und es war das
ende der dinosaurier im gegensatz zu den
dinosauriern leben wir heute in dem
bewusstsein dass unsere zeit auf erden
endlich ist und dass ein asteroid nieder
donnern und uns auslöschen könnte eine
ganz schön beängstigende vorstellung von
der man 2013 in der russischen
millionenstadt tscheljabinsk
schon einen kleinen vorgeschmack bekam
über der stadt der platz sei metroid mit
nur 19 metern durchmesser nur 30
kilometer über der erdoberfläche zur
basta mit der 40 fachen kraft der
hiroshima-bombe die enorme druckwelle
brachte fenster zum springen und dächer
kraft nein was blieb waren hunderte
verletzte ein sachschaden von 30
millionen dollar und 1 6000 kilo also
sechs tonnen schweres bruchstück des
asteroiden das später in einem
zugefrorenen see gefunden wurde
außerdem blieb natürlich die frage wie
wir so etwas in zukunft verhindern
können um das herauszufinden brauchen
wir ballistische experimente im ganz
grossen format also explosionen im
weltall
aber diese sind ausgesprochen teuer und
ihnen wird selten wissenschaftliche
priorität eingeräumt
deshalb gibt es eine ganze menge nicht
finanzierter planetary die fans mission
also verteidigungs missionen für unseren
planeten auch der kernphysiker holger
sierks vom max planck institut für
sonnensystemforschung hofft dass endlich
gelder durch den ministerrat der
europäischen raumfahrtbehörde esa
bewilligt werden um eine planetare
verteidigungs mission zu realisieren in
vier jahren soll diese mission eine
sonde namens hera zum doppel asteroiden
die demos schicken diese soll nachdem
die nasa die die moon den kleineren
körper des doppel asteroiden geschossen
hat die entstandene einstiegsstelle
vermessen ganze 270 millionen dollar
soll die esa für diese mission bezahlen
um am ende ein foto eine 16 millionen
kilometer entfernten kraters zu haben
ein verdammt eures foto aber auch ein
verdammt wichtiges der duisburger
geophysiker kein wunder man sagt wir
brauchen das hehre experiment nicht um
herauszufinden dass wir einen körper aus
der baden stoßen können davon gehe ich
aus wir wissen nur gerne wie er genau
das macht was wir wollen schon fast
seine ganze karriere lang fiebert der
geophysiker der gelegenheit entgegen so
einen künstlich erzeugten krater im all
zu untersuchen einmal sogar hat er es
getan
ja fast na ja das ganze lief so ab 2005
konnte er in den usa die deep impact
mission begleiten damals wollte man eine
hindernis in die bahn eines kometen
legen um material aus seinem inneren
herauszubrechen man wollte die beim
aufprall freiwerdenden teilchen
untersuchen um etwas über die urmaterie
zu erfahren
die in den kometen durchs all fliegt
einfluss auf die flugbahn des körpers zu
nehmen war damals noch gar nicht die
intention man hätte den krater auch
nicht untersuchen können im moment der
kollision raste die sonde so schnell an
dem kometen vorbei dass man den grad an
gar nicht sehen konnte erst jahre später
entstand ein bild davon allerdings auf
so große entfernung dass der krater nur
die größe eines bild pixels hatte heute
weiß man dass die nähere betrachtung
solcher charta extrem wichtig ist und
dass man für detaillierte erkenntnisse
realen weltraumbedingungen braucht ein
experiment das auf der erde einen krater
von einem halben meter hinterlässt kann
auf einem asteroiden die 100 bis 200
fache fläche umwälzen auf so einer
großen fläche muss viel mehr aufwand
betrieben werden um einen impuls bis in
die tiefe eines asteroiden zu bringen
außerdem sind die teilweise so porös die
asteroiden dass ein einschuss nur die
hohlräume verdichtet und die ganze stoß
energie einfach verpuffen würde ein stoß
impuls wäre also alles andere als
effektiv um mehr darüber zu erfahren
braucht man die vermessung eines
künstlichen kraters unter den echten
schwerelosen bedingungen im weltall
auch die größe von asteroiden
beeinflusst wie man sie unschädlich
machen kann bis zu einer größe von 500
meter könnte man sie wohl mit einem
inspektor einem schweren projektil
beschießen bis zu 1000 metern größe
bräuchten wir schon nukleare sprengsätze
um sie vom kurs abzubringen und körper
mit über einem kilometer durchmesser
sind im wahrsten sinne des wortes
schwere brocken für die abwehr
zumal sie auch mit 50.000
stundenkilometern heranrasenden harris
vom deutschen zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt sagt wir könnten es mit
mehreren nuklearsprengköpfen gestaffelt
versuchen aber ich bin nicht sehr
optimistisch das einzig beruhigende ist
dass die objekte sich in kreisen
fortbewegen und einem ein stark mehreren
nahe vorbeiflüge vorausgehen dadurch
sind wir zumindest jahrzehnte wenn nicht
jahrhunderte vor einem aufprall gewarnt
wie zb beim sogenannten weltuntergangs
asteroiden menü dessen eintreffen für
2135 prognostiziert wurde 2880 könnte
ein asteroid vor der amerikanischen
ostküste ins meer stürzen wir haben also
wenigstens noch zeit um gegen maßnahmen
auszuarbeiten experten ein experte im
forschen auch an minimal invasiven
maßnahmen um asteroiden einstecken
abzuwehren man könnte die oberfläche mit
einem laserstrahl gezielt zum kochen
bringen und den dampfstrahler dann wie
eine steuer düse einsetzen ähnliches
wäre mit ionenstrahlen möglich aber bei
all der feucht die mit einem möglichen
einschlag auf unserem blauen planeten
einher geht darf man nicht vergessen
dass wir solche kollisionen auch unser
leben zu verdanken haben ohne dem
zusammenprall mit einem anderen körper
während der mond nicht aus der erde
heraus gesplittert wie es die impact
theorie besagt und das sauerstoff in
form von eiskristallen auf die erde kam
ist wahrscheinlich ebenfalls auf einen
einschlag zurückzuführen hoffen trotzdem
dass wir noch rechtzeitig die richtigen
abwehrstrategien finden um in vielen
jahren ein armageddon verhindern zu
können denn wenn das leben auf der erde
ausgelöscht wird ist es auch kein trost
dass davor mal von asteroiden das leben
auf der erde gebracht wurde bombardement
wie reagiert die erde auf diverse
asteroiden anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren 2x kosmos neuer cooler kanal
in unserem wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054
also unbedingt anklicken es lohnt sich
bis dann bleibt dran